[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
so we make way for Brian Costello Jets
beat reporter for the New York Post Bry
thanks for joining us let me start with
our poll question which fan base should
feel better today the Packers or the
Jets
I think the Jets fan base should feel
better because you know you know even uh
I I laugh people talk about down year
for Aaron Rodgers he drew 26 touchdowns
you want to make Jets quarterbacks just
run 26 touchdowns about three right in
Ryan Fitzpatrick Joe Namath and Mark
Sanchez had a year 26. that's it so
Jordan love is an unknown to me I feel
like you know the Jets fan should feel a
little bit better this morning what kind
of team is he joining
a young team uh but a team with a lot of
Promise uh the defense number four in
the NFL last year they have sauce
Gardner Quinn and Williams two good
young players they don't have many holes
on defense uh Gary Wilson offensive
rookie of the year they sign Alan Lazard
Bruce Halls coming back from an ACL
we'll see where he is
the question really to me Dan is the
offensive line and they have work to do
there there's going to be some work I
think Thursday night on the offensive
line in the first round of the draft
but it you know they went they went
seven and ten last year with really poor
play at quarterback so they their
feeling is if they can get that
quarterback position fixed they're a
playoff team what do you think they're
going to do with that first John draft
pick
it's interesting because the you know
the pick swap they move back to picks
but now you know the Patriots are ahead
of them they might take offensive line
the Bears eagles they could take
offensive line so I do think the Jets
want to take a tackle uh they may be
staring at the fourth best tackle now
and see if they do that do they want to
trade back and recoup some picks uh
right now they have five draft picks to
you know does Joe Douglas want to move
back a little bit pivot to something
else but I really think that tackle you
know is a glaring need on this team and
you you have to be as good as Aaron
Rodgers is you have to protect them
I know that Ryan gudacons the Packers GM
wanted to get this deal done before the
draft I was told that that it was
probably going to get done uh prior to
the start of Friday's second round uh
were the Jets trying to you know push
this off to get it to the second round
on Friday no because you know Dan this
is a complicated deal right so it's it's
actually not official right now yet
because Rogers has to rework his
contract with the Packers to help them
cap wise
he has to be on there on their their
books on that contract for 24 hours so
they basically have to do that today
okay get that contract to the league the
league has to then approve it then the
trade can become official four o'clock
Wednesday you kind of Roger's gonna have
to take a physical I think that'll be
Wednesday for the Jets so there's some
moving pieces here it's not like just
trading picks right so doing this Friday
would have been hard I think that's what
the timing was okay and this way
everything is done by the time the draft
starts what would be considered a
successful season this year
well that's gonna be a moving Target
right now sitting here playoffs they
haven't made the playoffs in 12 years
but you know if they start ten and one
or something like that you're going to
be talking Super Bowl and the
expectations are going to rise but in
terms of like jobs losing jobs as a
coach DM you'll fire I think if they
need the playoffs that's that's a major
accomplishment it's been 12 years
um but yeah we saw it last year with the
Jets when they went when they were five
and two the expectation has Rose from
where they were you know how a season
unfolds changes things but sitting here
right now making the playoffs has to be
the expectation gosh I would feel like
as good as this team is with that that
uh defense
AFC title game feels like that would
that would be the expectation I would
have as a Jets fan is that is that fair
I think it's fair yeah I don't think
they're in you know I still think
they're a little below Buffalo Kansas
City Cincinnati right they've done it we
need to see the Jets do it and so but I
yeah I think if you're hoping fantasy
title game I think that's fair
um but you know this this we have to see
how it comes together like I said
offensive line how the injuries go how's
the schedule unfold you know all those
there's a lot of variables in in terms
of how far you get in the playoffs has
uh Robert Sala talked about Aaron
Rodgers or coaching him or how do you
think that relationship's gonna go I
think this would be good he they they
actually practice Dan the Jetson Packers
practice together they did joint
practices in the summer of 21 in Green
Bay Robert Sala and Matt leflore are
best friends uh they're in each other's
weddings they coached together 20 years
ago at Central Michigan so he knows
Aaron Rodgers a little bit Rogers has
said when Salah got the Jets job he
actually spoke to him and congratulated
there and so there's a little bit of a
relationship there Salah has spoken
glowingly about Rogers when they
practice together when they played
before last year they played at Lambeau
um you know I think it'll go well you
know the the balance stand with these
things is always how much control do you
give that great veteran quarterback yeah
versus not making it a situation where
he's completely elevated above the team
the Buccaneers I think with Brady had to
feel their way that first season in
doing that and Nathaniel Hackett who's
now the Jets offensive coordinator went
through this last year in Denver with
Russell Wilson and by all accounts it
seems like he gave him too much power
there
how much easier is your job now that
Aaron Rodgers is in town the the job is
good my life might not be easier my my
wife's not going to be happy but yeah
and and looked in covering the Jets 1pm
Sundays have been great for a long time
writes on Deadline I'm going now I'm
like oh my gosh there's gonna be Sunday
night games I might be in Dallas on
Thanksgiving it's like all of a sudden
that part of it but business business
will be very good with Aaron Rodgers who
do you think the Jets open up with I'm
assuming that Sunday night NBC game
yeah I would think Buffalo you know is
probably a good candidate that would be
a very attractive matchup just these two
powers in the AFC East
um you know the the AFC West is on the
schedule this year so there's Kansas
City that you know that could be uh
Kansas City open on that Thursday night
I haven't studied their schedule who
they'll play but yeah I have a feeling
that you know the Jets are gonna be in
prime time in week one and they'll be in
Prime Time a lot this season
Brian thank you good luck
thanks Dan thanks for having me Brian
Costello Jets beat reporter for the New
York Post which he's done for quite some
time